this is our time for analyzing some Mi
the a-hole moral quandries we have some
that were sent to us by listeners and
then we've got I'll do one from
from Reddit why is it always ready so we
start with this from Ty says my fiance
wants to try having kids shortly after
we get married this Summer while we're
both on board with that plan I want to
stop at just one and she definitely
wants many more children I'm aware that
if neither of us changes our mind one of
us will get what we want and the other
will be crushed I being the selfish
bastard that I am and planning on
putting my foot down when push comes to
shove and our first kid reaches two or
three years old and she will want to try
again am I the a-hole for not being very
transparent in my plan after our first
kid is born I'm 100 firm on this and as
a last resort if my back is up against
the wall I'm not opposed to getting the
snip but I hope it doesn't come to that
uh yeah you are the a-hole on a few
different levels I mean first of all if
you're even considering getting the snip
as you say
medical
procedure uh and that's that's something
that you would do against your
soon-to-be wife's wishes then that that
is something that she needs to know you
need to tell her that also don't don't
do that don't go don't go neuter
yourself like a dog
you're a man you're a human being don't
do that to yourself look how about this
for an idea right you both want a child
so it's good that you agree on that much
so get married have your child allow
yourself to grow and change my point is
that there's a very good chance that
you'll have one child and then you'll
discover yourself that you actually want
to have more because right now you're
speaking all in in theory and you've
never had a kid before so you you can't
you know you don't really know what
you're talking about
and um once you experience that Joy of
having a child there's a very good
chance that you're gonna you're gonna
change your mind about that the joy of
having a child is one that again it's
it's hard to like describe until you've
actually experienced it allow yourself
to have you know you have the child uh
and you you should be open to life you
should be open to uh more kids if that's
what God wants for you
uh but you also need to be totally
honest with the woman that you're about
to marry all right uh Mary says hello
Sweet Daddy am I the a-hole for not
encouraging my husband to have a
relationship with his father or Father's
family for some backstory my husband's
parents divorced when he was 17. his dad
was verbally abusive tried to instigate
a fight with my brother-in-law when my
husband was younger and hit his wife my
husband was a witness to it all whose
wife who's hitting whose wife your dad
hit your your brother-in-law's wife or
my okay so there's some kind of abuse
going on which is very bad after my
husband and I started dating I tried to
get my husband to have more of a
relationship with his father since his
father had promised that he had changed
and wanted to be better I kept at it for
years just reminding him to text on
holidays birthdays and go see him at the
yearly family reunion on his father's
side a year after my husband and I had
our wedding we attended the family
reunion at this reunion my father-in-law
kept talking crap about my mother-in-law
and had his family joining in making
both his sons very uncomfortable later
my father-in-law wanted to take a family
photo of his immediate family when my
husband and I started it over to the
spot for the photo his father called out
not you girl then did not want me in any
of the other family photos either this
hurt me deeply so we left early after
that then afterwards I come to find out
his father doesn't like me at all and
blames me for the lack of relationship
with the son my husband told him he
won't speak to him anymore until he
apologizes to me am I the a-hole for no
longer encouraging my husband to make
their relationship work well these are
always really difficult and um
you know I get these kinds of questions
and you're talking about family drama
and resentment and all these sorts of
things have been building up over the
course of years have you thought about
the possibility that your children are
actually scared of you oh off he's
almost certainly going to be a bunch of
other details that don't make it in here
and part of that is just time
constraints part of it is also that you
are seeing things through your own prism
and if I were to talk to your
father-in-law he might have some other
details he might he might say well guess
what guess what she did there's almost
always more to the story it's it's it's
very often there's not a there's not a
clear bad guy I mean sometimes there is
but some but oftentimes there isn't so
that's all just to qualifier to say that
based on what you've told me if all this
is accurate which I have no reason to
think that it isn't I don't know you
then uh no you're not the a-hole at all
and also in general even even though I
don't know all the rest of the situation
your husband is absolutely right to take
your side and defend you as the wife to
cherish his relationship with you and to
put it over as a priority above his
relationship to anybody else in his
family because that's what you're
supposed to do when you get married that
your relationship with your spouse comes
before your relationship with anyone
else to include your children by the way
your relationship with your spouse is
supposed to be the number one most
important thing and uh it comes before
everything else certainly you know
extended family but even even with your
kids like you're that's what your kids
need your kids need their parents to
prioritize a relationship with each
other it's the best thing for them you
know you've heard me talk about how
important it is to have a VPN to protect
your online privacy but choosing a VPN
you trust is equally as important I like
to do my research on my sponsors and I
only recommend Brands to my listeners
that I believe in to actually stop
people from monitoring your online
activity you need to do what I do and
use expressvpn think about all the times
you've used Wi-Fi at a coffee shop Hotel
even a friend's house without expressvpn
every site you visit can be logged by
the Admin of that Network that's still
true even when you're in incognito mode
especiallypn is an app that encrypts all
of your network data and reroutes it
through a network of secure servers so
that your private online activity stays
private expressvpn works on all your
devices it's super easy to use the app
has one button you tap it to connect and
your browsing activity is secure stop
letting strangers invade your online
privacy protect yourself and
expressvpn.com
walshyt use my Link at expressvpn.com
walshyt to get three extra months free
that's exp
ressvpn.com
walshyt all right from Steve says I
appreciate you taking the time to answer
my question I have a zero tolerance
policy when it comes to excessive gifts
from my mother-in-law let me elaborate
my mother-in-law is a hoarder in every
sense of the word her house is
completely full with random toys kitchen
accessories Etc to the point where I
have told my wife I don't even want to
visit because there are literally very
few places where someone can even sit
down let alone relax do the amount of
stuff all over the place on top of
filling up our house she is always
bringing things over to our house that
we don't want we've told her repeatedly
over the years that when she comes we
only want to spend time with her not go
through all the things that she brings
when we refuse the things she brings she
has taken to leaving things in our house
without us knowing thinking we would
notice I asked her many times to stop
and when she didn't I took to throwing
away anything that she left when she
notices that things are gone I told her
that I don't know where they are I know
she thinks she's being generous and
giving us gifts but if we're keeping
everything that she brings to the house
our house will end up looking like hers
am I the ale no you're not I mean as
long as you're as long as you're being
nice to her about it I mean she's trying
to love her family in the way that makes
sense to her and so she thinks that by
giving gifts that's the way of doing it
and so she's trying to to bless you and
and even if it's a way that's sort of
annoying and ends up being onerous and
burdensome that is what she's trying to
do so as long as you're being nice to
her about it and trying to be delicate
um then uh then no you're not neither of
you are exactly in the wrong finally
this is a Reddit one says am I the
a-hole for refusing to help my sister
pay for her daughter's medical expenses
so my sister's daughter sentence
starting with so there how I feel about
that my sister's daughter was recently
diagnosed with a serious medical
condition that requires extensive
treatment my sister is a single mother
struggling to pay for the treatment on
her own
she asked me multiple times to help her
with the expense but I have refused my
reasoning is that I have my own
financial responsibilities and I can't
afford to help her out I also believe
that it's not my responsibility to take
care of her and her family's expenses my
sisters understandably upset with my
decision has stopped talking to me my
other family members are also
disappointed in me and think that I
should have helped her out my the a-hole
for refusing to help my sister with her
daughter's medical expenses uh yes yes
this is classic a-hole territory this is
one of those times where I don't need to
hear the other side of the story
actually because I've heard enough this
is horrible now it's one thing look you
have somebody in your family who's
suffering through something
and they need help financially
and you simply don't have like you can't
help them because you really don't have
it you're you're broke you're poor you
just you don't you don't eat it and it
pains you you want to be able to help
but you can't because you just don't
have it that's one thing but then but
then the tone and the attitude would be
very different
then you wouldn't need to say anything
about it if this is your family it's not
my problem you wouldn't need to say that
you wouldn't say that instead it would
be I'm I'm distraught by this it's
terrible it's heartbreaking I want to
help but I just can't I wish that I
could that would be the attitude what I
take from this is that uh probably you
can help but you've decided that it's
not your problem and that is the height
of selfishness I mean this is your
family and if you won't even do that
then you are a selfish bastard and an
a-hole and we will leave it there for
today uh we'll talk to you tomorrow
Godspeed
[Music]
ready